qui avait intérêt à assassiner le
responsable du programme nucléaire
iranien est atterrant mohsen fahmy
d'asie il a été tué dans un attentat
terroriste
alors qui dit moins c'est ce que dit à
téhéran alors qu'il était dans sa
voiture lui aussi plusieurs autres
personnes tuées et il les attaquants
sont morts également
l'iran accuse déjà israël d'être
derrière l'attaqué qu'israël ça veut
dire le mossad
le ministre des affaires étrangères a
écrit sur twitter
des terroristes ont assassiné un éminent
scientifique iranien aujourd'hui cette
lâcheté avec des sérieuses indications
sur l'euro israélien montre le
bellicisme désespérée des auteurs l'iran
appelle la communauté internationale et
en particulier l'union européenne à
mettre fin à leur double standard
honteux a condamné cet acte de
terrorisme d'état
mon invité thomas gino professeur à
l'école d'affaires publiques et
internationales de l'université période
en sortons maginot alors cet assassinat
survient quand même deux semaines à
peine après qu'on ait appris qu le
président entre hommes voulaient faire
une frappe en iran et que son entourage
immédiat est paraît-il pomme p o
aurel laurent l'aurait empêché l'an neuf
empêché alors qu'ils avaient intérêt à
cette exécution aujourd'hui c'est
toujours dur à dire surtout le jour même
parce qu'on est encore dans le domaine
de la spéculation tacle pas
d'informations plus précises elle mais à
ce stade si tous les yeux sont tournés
vers israël et quand on essaie de
comprendre les motifs d'israël on peut
les voir deux niveaux premièrement
israël mène une guerre clandestine
contre l'iran depuis plusieurs années il
ya eu des absences des assassinats de
ingénieur nucléaire iranien au fil des
années particulièrement 2010 et 2012
et ça ça continue mais aussi une
hypothèse qui circule beaucoup mais moi
j'ai tendance à lille est sympathique
leur à croire qu'elle est plausible
c'est qu'israël veut mettre des bâtons
dans les roues de la future
administration byden en rendant un
éventuel retour aux négociations
nucléaires entre les etats-unis l'iran
plus difficile on va revenir à cette
entente à ce traité que trois pas
déchirer mais aussi c'est que la semaine
dernière
netanyahu qui ciblait déjà
ce scientifique comme un ennemi d'israël
dans différentes conférences quoi j'ai
vu de passer des photos de son
aujourd'hui est allé en arabie saoudite
rencontré le prince héritier en
compagnie de pompey aux grillades ni la
rencontre il serait là la publiciste
d'une certaine manière est ce qu'on peut
voir un lien entre les deux à ce niveau
là je serai plus prudent d'abord israël
est extrêmement prudent en général quant
à la circulation de l'information pour
des opérations aussi sensible que ça ce
qu israël on aurait parlé directement
avec l'arabie saoudite la semaine
dernière dans cette fameuse rencontre le
sait pas impossible mais j'en doute
ce qu israël on aurait parlé aux états
unis dans les derniers jours pour avoir
une lumière verte
ça c'est le possible c'est même très
possible mais de là à parler de
collusion ou de coopération avec
l'arabie saoudite spécifiquement le
sujet et autres je pense que de manière
plus générale ce qu israël et l'arabie
saoudite essaye de faire c'est ce que
j'ai mentionné il ya deux minutes c'est
à dire rendre la vie de la future
administration de ne plus compliqué sans
nécessairement s'entendre sur tous les
détails
et justement donc d'une vue reprendre
les discussions pour signer à nouveau je
pense que cela impliquerait une nouvelle
entente et qui étaient décriées par par
tromper misé beaucoup là dessus à trois
d'ailleurs oui alors l'abstration jump
est sortie de l'accord sur le nucléaire
en 2018 cet accord là est encore en vie
mais vraiment sur le respirateur
artificiel avec les états européens la
russie la chine et l'iran c'est pas
évident pour les états unis de juste
réintégrer cet accord là parce que le
temps est passé il ya des délais qui
sont expirés ya beaucoup de dommages qui
a été fait je pense que ce qui est plus
plausible c'est une renégociation d'un
nouvel accord 2.0 si on veut mais ça va
être très compliqué je leur ai déjà été
avant les événements d'aujourd'hui là ça
va juste l'être un peu plus faut
s'attendre à une réaction maintenant du
nouveau secrétaire d'état désignée
monsieur blinken ou encore monsieur
byden à ce moment c'est parce que pour
l'instant washington ne réagit pas de
l'entourage semble e10 ou et bessat il
faut que l'administration va de ne fasse
attention parce qu' elle n'est pas
encore au pouvoir alors de façon
générale la migration des données a été
très prudente à ne pas gouverner avant
le 20 janvier et ça je m'attends à ce
que de manière officielle ça continue on
en même temps est ce qu'il faut craindre
des représailles de terrasser la menace
qui est fait aujourd'hui
oui on la question des reprises de
terrain est très importante si on se
rappelle par exemple l'art janvier
dernier quand les états unis avaient
assassiné le général souleymane sy la
prédiction que plusieurs avaient fait
donc moi qui en gros c'est ce qui s'est
passé c'est que l'iran ne va pas
répondre de manière immédiate et directe
parce que dans cette éventualité là il y
aurait eu risque d'escaladé en cas
d'escaladé l'iran par contre les états
unis parce que les états unis sont
beaucoup plus puissants plus tôt la
réponse iranienne
après les événements de janvier dernier
je m'attends à ce que ce soit la même
chose dans les prochains mois
c'est que ce soit une réponse est
directe par des cyber attaques par des
groupes armés que l'iran soutient à
travers la région de manière non
conventionnelle et surtout peut-être en
2021 peut-être en mars peut être
dangereux sa voix est étalée dans le
temps parce que l'iran veut quand même
toujours évité un scénario d' escalade
sur bayonne a intérêt à négocier
rapidement avant que ces représailles ne
survienne monsieur bré de intérêts
légaux si rapidement mais je ne crois
pas qu'il sera capable parce que hein ça
va des négociation extraordinairement
compliquée au niveau technique et
politique autant aux états unis qu'en
iran et deux coureuses qu'il faut pas
oublier c'est que des élections
présidentielles en iran au printemps
prochain
il savait difficile pour l'iran de
bouger avant ça donc les négociations
vont s'étaler sur plusieurs mois donc à
suivre
moi je ne remercie beaucoup bonne soirée
et bon ok moi qui vous remercie allah